so let's step onto the land of
sturdiness that is bitcoin
what is bitcoin and um in your view what
are
you know the principles the
philosophical foundations of bitcoin
well bitcoin the term i think refers to
two things specifically
so one is the protocol for conveying
value through communications channel
so just a set of rules that we
collectively opt into
in order to transact online or just add
a distance
and then the other thing is the name of
the
asset the sort of monetary unit which
circulates
within the system and that always
confuse people a lot because it's like
well you've got uppercase bitcoin
lowercase bitcoin
why didn't satoshi you just give them
different names like in ethereum you've
got ethereum
the system and then ether although
people don't really talk about
ether very much but they you know chose
to distinguish them
in bitcoin for whatever reason they're
not distinct
uh so the two bitcoins get co-mingled
all the time
in the explanations did you find that's
a problem that confuses things
i mean what's what's really a
distinction between the protocol and the
currency
well they are sometimes uh distinguished
practically
like you can transact with bitcoin
outside of the bitcoin protocol for
instance
right uh so you know you can transact
with bitcoin on
ethereum or i have bitcoin on an open
dime here
this would be a bitcoin transaction it
wouldn't settle on the bitcoin network
you